and with val deming set to take on marco
rubio as brett just mentioned this fall
we know that she's become the latest
darling of the liberal media complex
from the washington post resident grump
trump-hating liberal jennifer rubin
don't underestimate val deming she's got
marco rubio pegged
not sure what that even means but we've
seen this before right a big name
republican is challenged and the media
swoons then the money starts rolling in
great expectations greater war chest in
fact deming's fundraising has outpaced
rubio's this year and she's out spending
in more than two to one
but is money dispositive in a race like
this in 2018 beto o'rourke broke the
fundraising record for a single quarter
leading up to the election but of course
he still lost to ted cruz
kentucky state senator and navy fighter
pilot amy mcgrath brought in nearly 90
million dollars trying to unseat mitch
mcconnell in 2020
she lost by the close margin of 20
points
and despite breaking uh just about every
senate fundraising record with nearly
110 million dollars coming in in 2020
democrat jamie harrison was beaten by
lindsey graham
by pretty healthy 10 points
and
come on newt gingrich who knows more
about this fox news contributor and
author of defeating big government
socialism joins me now
now mr speaker
republican governor turned independent
senate candidate turned i think i have
this right democrat senate candidate uh
as brett mentioned charlie the crispy
crist he won his primary gonna take on
ron desantis in november should desantis
be worried here newt
oh god i think i've known charlie chris
since he was a republican state senator
in 1984
at the reagan convention in dallas
i think charlie would be
a great model for a broadway play that
was a musical comedy because his whole
life is amazing
i mean he was a democrat he's a
republican he's an independent but he
has huge staying power
and i think ron desantis needs to beat
somebody by a big margin i think that
charlie's a perfect example and i think
ron will come out of the governor
desantis will come out of this general
election with probably a huge the
biggest margin in modern times for a
republican and that's a pretty good base
for him to be thinking in the long run
about a national career but charlie's
just
i mean he doesn't exist i mean he's pure
he's pure ego he has no political stance
he has no platform that matters he has
no values that matter but he's a very
likable very energetic
very persistent guy and he obviously can
raise enough money to win a primary so
it's fun it's not serious and ron
desantis is the next governor
now remember of course christ tried
unsuccessfully
to take out marco rubio
uh in this in the senate as well
um
but now the media is certainly rooting
for val demings watch this newt
i think val demings may have the best
chance of pillowing off an upset marco
rubio is in real trouble i don't think
anybody expected marco rubio to be in
trouble he is val demings is a dream
candidate for the democrats we see it in
the enthusiasm the fundraising
new the media adoration sounds and looks
familiar to me she was obviously a
orlando police chief for four years she
was first lady uh when her husband was
mayor of a florida town um she's well
known in the state i think she's pretty
well liked thoughts
look you know and she
seems to be a responsible nice person
but first of all she's going to be part
of the
biden
campaign team she will never be able to
get out from under biden
so it'll be the biden demings race and
i'm sure the rubio's people are good
enough they'll make that really clear
but second
she's she's really the tradition of beta
o'rourke remember beta o'rourke was the
magic person who was going to beat ted
cruz he raised an enormous amount of
money
more than i would have thought possible
and he collapsed totally because in the
end i mean how is she going to explain
she was in washington
she did vote for all these crazy things
she cannot defend any of them
she is in fact a biden democrat because
everybody who's running this year is a
biden democrat and in the end that's
going to crush her so marco rubio is a
great great speaker of the house great
u.s senator uh i think will in fact
go on to win election again probably by
one of the surprisingly biggest margins
you know florida used to be a very
closely fought state but i think between
desantis and rubio we're going to start
seeing big margins in florida and they
had a big event i believe it was this
week together which you might probably
going to see more of those down the line
newt great to see you tonight thanks so
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else